hey rich how are you what's up man
i find very well um i i got your book
recently i've been reading it i'm about
like a couple chapters in it's really
good thank you good
how old are you by the way
yeah okay so pardon how old are you by
the way i'm 18. you're 18 and you're
asking about having children
yeah all right
go for pregnant is that what you're
dropping on me no no no no no
good all right
okay so um your your um content has
really helped me with red pill awareness
and even before that uh one thing that
my dad would always tell me was um one
of the main ways you will like the main
way you can ruin your life as a young
person is to impregnate someone you know
by mistake and even if that doesn't
happen um a lot of women nowadays run a
lot of danger with divorce and with
raising children so my question to you
is i'm
supposing like because i want to have a
son eventually one day maybe when i'm 35
or 40
supposing like i don't know maybe maybe
this is ignorant to think right now but
i i would raise him alone or just like
you know raise him i know it would be
ideal to have a two people household
like a mom and a dad but supposing that
wouldn't be the case if it's just me
raising my son could that have any side
effects on him
um
children are always gonna do better with
a mother and a father raising them
always there's absolutely no question
about it you're setting your kid off in
society
um
at a significant disadvantage
um not to say you can't do it i mean 43
of households today um
are single single parent households so
most kids are being raised by a single
parent and by that they mean the mother
so
you're going to have the struggle of
well how do i acquire
custody of this child
like you're basically talking about
raising the child by yourself so
you either need her to give up
parental rights which you probably won't
do because she'll be enriched by being
the parent from you and from the
government or you have to have a um
surrogate you're gonna have to hire a
lady and basically buy an egg
you know do a little magic under a
microscope somebody does it for you and
they plant the egg in her and boom
you've got a baby nine months later
and she's under contract so she has to
give it up so she's just a surrogate
she's like a she's like the oven that
you bake the
bun it sort of thing
um so there's that but um
i mean you're asking an interesting
question for an 18 year old because i
mean you're saying that this is really
something 17 years down the road for you
you know 17 to 20 years down the road
for you which it should be you know it's
totally fine um
so
so here's what's important live where
shared custody is by default there's
there's states you know if you go to
wikipedia and you search on wikipedia
for shared custody states
find out what states by default offer
shared parenting in case there's a
divorce so at least that way you don't
have to fight on that or it's an easy
fight
okay
and then you live there
you know you live there so that's one
thing two
be fully red pill aware like
make sure you're not watching youtube as
a red pill masturbator just watching
people's channels or even worse
looking at entertainment shows where
it's like you know you see these guys
that bring on like these drunken title
checks and they're [ __ ] like let's
make an example of them
that's not red pill awareness that's
that's watching bratty [ __ ] you know
behave badly that's what the tv show
should be called bratty [ __ ] is
behaving badly
yeah
um
so make sure that you're that you're
fully aware like you've got frame okay
when it comes comes to women like i was
talking earlier at the start of the show
about like serious advanced levels of
frame like i have guys that they're in
my community that like have a date lined
up and if she flakes
they're like that's it you're done
but they got like eight other options in
their phone right right there and then
right so they're in a very good position
um
so being properly red pillow wear having
good frame with women is very very
important it's it's probably
if i'm being honest if it comes to a
marriage the way marriage is operated in
north america with canada in the states
it's probably one of the most important
things
having a good prenup
um
you know making sure that you're her
hypergamous best so she's always looking
up at you these are all really important
things i i've i've got a course that i'm
gonna put together and all these things
so it'll be available i mean you know
you don't have to worry about this in
the next 17 years dude but it's a very
good question
yeah thank you yeah so i've heard about
the surrogate thing and and i've got
like you know still a long time to come
i've really considered it but i don't
know if they're um
how would you say like because the
reason i i don't i don't want to adopt
and i don't care if this first people's
feelings is because that that's kind of
cuckold or you know what i mean like i
want to have my kid with my dna i want
to pass my name down the line you know i
don't want to so
so
so here's the thing i mean you know
you're talking about surrogates you're
talking about like a single parent
household but what happens if you know
during the course of your life as you're
chasing excellence you're starting to
make some bank you know you've got some
social influence you throw some more
muscle on your frame you know you learn
combat skill sports you know like all
this sort of stuff and you level up and
your smv starts to increase and all of a
sudden
all these hot women are throwing
attention at you you're spinning some
plates the cream rises at the top what
happens if at like 35 and she's 27 you
know she's getting close to the epiphany
phase she's like
i totally dig your vibe i'll do anything
for you she's all over you like a fat
kid on cake
you know you've got her wrapped around
your finger she loves you to bits you
know she wants to have children with you
okay
i'm just throwing it out there right
what if
so
there's a lot of questions that could
come your way in the next 17 years it's
good that you're asking them certainly
entertain them
but um
don't let any of that trump you know you
finding a purpose in life right now
yeah that's the most important thing
worry about kids later i mean you got
lots of runway for that
yeah
all right
yeah yeah uh because uh yeah well just
uh
one more thing i wanted to ask oh yeah
i just kind of two questions so the
first one is um what do you think about
because i've heard andrew tate um say
this how like um
like for example let's say like i mean
maybe if you're a muslim you know you
you could be married with multiple women
if you can support them like financially
but um
you know you weren't religious what do
you what do you think about the idea of
like like you being a man of like having
uh many women that are loyal to you once
you're a high value man what do you
think about that it's not as easy as you
think like abu american um
he's on twitter is his um handle
and he's got a youtube channel uh he's
muslim
you know as a muslim you can have up to
four wives
i believe if i'm not mistaken uh but
he's been divorced 12 times so he's got
two wives right now
and he's got
i think he said 12 divorces behind him
so
um
like there's some sorting through
women that you're going to have to go
through
and the more women you have in your life
i'll tell you right now the more
complicated your life is going to be um
i know several guys that um have
like exclusive relationships with with
several women meaning they're exclusive
to him
but he's not exclusive to them and he's
got two three four of them in some cases
they have children with them
and
they all have
[ __ ] that they gotta deal with you know
with these chicks like you invite
multiple women in your life you're gonna
have multiple problems for multiple
women they've got you know they've got
friends each they've got family each
they've got drama that comes up they're
on their own menstrual cycle at
different times of the month
it's not easy peasy it's not like as
easy and simple and fun as you think
sure you're gonna have some variety and
sure you can you know raise the pimp
hand high you know sort of thing
um
but there's a cost that's associated to
it and really
you can't pull that off unless you're
like in the top
tenth of a percent of men out there okay
like the like the top one percent
and lower you got to be in that category
like you have to make serious money you
got to have serious game with women um
they have to have the ability to look
the other way when you go and do what
you want when you want and be okay with
it right so all that stuff's really
really important to understand it's very
very complex but i mean like you're not
even there yet for that so it's so it's
a very like lean into the future
question
okay all right
yeah thanks a lot rich so i'm very happy
with yeah the book and i'll be doing a
favor yeah when you're done the book
guys leave a review on amazon and let
other guys know what value that you've
gotten out of it so it's available on
amazon print kindle and audible i
narrated the audible myself
um just check it out and uh leave a
review i mean that's what this um
podcast uh playlist is based on so
if that makes sense all right brother
yeah i think yeah actually i have a
youtube channel and i've recommended
your book i haven't like said what it's
about but i've recommended it many times
it's very good rich excellent
thank you all right man see you
you